et pour terminer ce journal je vous
propose de découvrir une comédie
musicale montée par jérôme savary
irma la douce sera l'ultime création du
célèbre metteur en scène au théâtre
national de chaillot
et pour interpréter son rôle principal
il a choisi la jeune et talentueuse
clotilde courau reportage dominique
poncet et laurence ou dans l'équipe de
chaillot c'est toujours comme ça à dix
minutes du lever de rideau au préfet
encore tous azimuts
la plupart des comédies musicales qu'on
vous propose à paris en ce moment c'est
du karaoké nous c'est du direct la
preuve regardez il y en avoir bien
légère avance m notre ils ont aussi joué
et dansé puisqu'il s'apprête à
interpréter
irma la douce pourquoi j'ai voulu monter
irma parce que c'est une histoire de
femmes en scène une femme qui décide de
faire ce qu'elle veut de son corps de
son âme et de son coeur
raconter son des musiques marguerite
monnot rien à la douche c'est l'histoire
d'une tendre fille de joie qu'ils
n'aimera jamais qu'un seul homme en 1956
fait la flamboyante colette renard qui
avait créé le rose pour lui succéder
je ressens la vie a choisi la douce
clotilde et euros depuis le 1er jour de
répétition elle a essayé de trouver de l
a beaucoup amené d'elle-même de trouver
irma la douce
moi ce qui me bouleverse et de chanter
chaque fois sa mort ça me fait tout
bizarre ça me fait bizarre
c'est tout
viniar a grenoble c'est chaque fois un
défi tellement immense et une tempête
tellement une son émotion mais aussi son
charme et sa vitalité
clotilde courau les transmet à tous ses
partenaires le résultat est que ces
firmes à la 12 mais d'entrée de la salle
dans sa poche